(upbeat music)
- Good morning, everyone,
perhaps good afternoon, good evening
wherever you're joining us from.
It's really a pleasure to be here,
I always enjoy spending
time with participants
in the CIFAR machine
learning, deep learning,
reinforcement learning summer school.
I'm a little bit sad we
can't do it in person
but really happy we have
time together today.
I'll share with you some of
the work that we've been doing.
This is work that's primarily
done with some of my students
at McGill University
over the last few years,
but I will say since
then it has really grown
throughout the community
and I've had the pleasure
of working on this topic
of how do we set up a
better set of experiments
for research and reinforcement learning
with people across the planet
who are really deeply involved
in raising our standards
in terms of the quality
of our experimental work.
And at the end of the talk,
hopefully I'll get there,
I will even have some suggestions and tips
if any of you want to get
involved into this work,
there's lots of ways that
you can actually participate
towards this effort.
Getting started,
one of the main reasons
I'm really interested
in making sure that we
have good experiments,
and we'll spend some time
sort of discussing today
what are the conditions for doing that
is because we are seeing the
speed at which AI in general,
but reinforcement learning
more specifically,
that we're moving from research
to technology development,
to deployed applications.
So really this pipeline of innovation
from really the inception of an idea
to having a product working in the world
is getting shorter over time,
whereas in other fields that
we've seen much, much longer
development time in AI
often it's the case that
a new algorithm comes up
and, you know, three months later
it's actually running and brought up.
And so that means that we have
really a high responsibility
in terms of making sure
that each of the step
of the development that we invest in
is actually done in a way
that meets our high standards of quality,
whether we're building navigation systems
for autonomous vehicles,
whether we're building chatbot
agents to allow interactions
between human and machines,
or whether we're developing and
deploying intelligent robots
to assist in surgery,
all of these cases where people have used
reinforcement learning
to improve the behavior
of the system,
I assure you that no matter
which of these system,
I'm also including top left an
example of energy management,
smart cities and grid system,
where we also have seen really
promising RL applications.
In all of these cases,
we want to make sure that when we run
a reinforcement learning
agent in real time,
that the performance
is going to be adequate
based on our expectation that
it's not going to cause harm,
that we can predict in advance
what will be the quality
level of that system.
And so that's really my deep motivation
and I'll share with you some applications
that we've worked in in our lab
that have motivated that more
immediately in our own work.
But really thinking broadly
about why do I think it's important for us
today together to speak about
conducting good experiments
this is the place where I'm coming from.
Now assume by now you
have a pretty good sense
of how to build a machine
learning pipeline,
and this is a very generic one,
but in many case you have this first phase
of getting the data,
and then there's another
phase of cleaning, preparing,
manipulating the data,
you may be training your
model, test your model,
after that and then you improve
and see what phase of the
system you need to go back to.
This is a pretty standard pipeline.
In reality, in each of these steps
there's a lot of decisions
that have to be made
about how you are going to set up this,
and this is what I'm calling
sort of the experimental pipeline,
how you're going to set
up each of these steps.
And if you're not careful
about really being precise
about your design choices
and furthermore documenting
them in a transparent way,
and can be quite difficult to
verify the quality of the work
that you're doing.
And so in a lot of the work that I do,
one of the key concepts that
arises in this discussion
of better experiments is the
notion of reproducibility.
And so reproducibility is really all about
having the ability to
duplicate an experiment,
to duplicate the results.
The goal of reproducibility
is really that we want
to achieve robustness,
and so the idea is that
if you run an experiment
and if you're able to run,
you or someone else is able to run
that same experiment again,
then you can have higher
confidence that the findings
or the conclusions of that experiments
are actually of a high-quality.
And this concept of reproducibility
actually permeates the world of science
it's not specific to AI
or reinforcement learning,
that's really very fundamental
to the scientific method.
And one of the reasons we
really emphasize reproducibility
is because it gives us this
high confidence in our findings.
And so really it will be the major theme
of what I talk about today,
when I talk about better experiments,
what really we're talking about
is how do we build experiments
that are reproducible,
experiments where we
can have high confidence
in the conclusions that we're drawing
from the results that are obtained.
There's actually been a lot of discussion
on the last few years
about what is the state
of reproducibility in science in general?
So I'm sharing here are the
quick snapshot of an article
published in the journal nature of 2016.
We are 1500 or so researchers were asked
whether they thought there
was a reproducibility crisis
within their field of science,
but 52% said, yes there's
a significant crisis,
38% said maybe a slight crisis
and a few of them didn't
seem to be very concerned
about the situation.
Now, beyond that, the
survey also asked, you know,
"Have you ever failed to
reproduce an experiment?"
And they asked both about whether you fail
to reproduce someone else's
experiment, so in darker red,
or whether you would fail to reproduce
one of your own
experiments, in lighter red.
And so what we see is that in many fields,
chemistry, biology,
upwards of 60% of researchers
have been the situation
where they were unable to reproduce
someone else's experiment
or their own experiment.
The computer science
doesn't really detail there,
we'll dig more into it today,
but even in the physics and engineering
where you would think
that perhaps it's easier
to reproduce experiments
compared to dealing with
maybe biology or chemistry,
still a very, very high rate of inability
to reproduce certain experiments.
So that sort of sets the
stage for where we're at.
In many ways when dealing
with machine learning,
there's a sense that we
should be able to do better,
you know, we can control much
more of the data that we use,
the algorithms that are running,
the machines on which these
algorithms are running.
And so in doing that,
we should be able to meet
a much higher standard
of reproducibility than
perhaps some of these fields
where there's a lot more
extraneous variables
that might affect the
result of the research.
So for those of you who are
interested in digging in
and seeing how we're doing
overall in machine learning,
I would recommend this very nice paper
published just a few years ago.
This researcher analyzed 250
so papers from several years
of machine learning research
and found that over that set of papers,
around 63% of them are
deemed reproducible.
We also dug in a little
bit more and analyzed
what were the factors that
affected reproducibility.
So these are factors
that I kind of come back
in our discussion today.
One of them is the
availability of pseudo code,
even better in some
cases, open source code.
One of them is a clear specification
of what are the hyper-parameters
that were considered in the experiments.
Another one is the
readability of the equations
and the tables.
In some cases,
if you're not able to really understand
whether the results
it's hard to make sure that
you are actually achieving them
when you run the reproducibility study.
A fourth one was the compute needed,
there's some work that is being produced
especially very recently,
that requires enormous
amounts of computation
which is perhaps not accessible.
Last one was the topic of the work,
so that seemed to be a main driver,
there is some subtopics
of machine learning
which are harder to reproduce than others.
The last point which I
didn't highlight here,
but also comes through if you
look at some of the P values
which indicate the significance
of a particular feature
and reproducibility is the
conversation with the authors.
So the ability to go back
and forth with the author
to have more detail about their experiment
turned out to be a determining factor
in the ability to reproduce experiments.
So quite interesting to keep in mind,
and I encourage each of you is interested
to go in and read the paper
and really learn what we can
from these many, many years
of experiments in machine learning
and the very nice analysis that was done.
That really starts giving
you a sense of what matters,
what are the types of
procedures and good habits
you need to build into
your own experiments
as you've ventured into
machine learning research.
Now, I want to just give a
little bit of a landscape
in terms of different terms
that are used across the community.
I will say with a bit of a caveat
that these terms are not
used always in the same way
across these disciplines,
I'm basing this by report
that the NSF National Science
Foundation in the U.S.
has issued recently about
the notion of reproducibility
trying to crystallize the
definition of these terms,
so that's the one I'm adopting today,
but I will just warn you
if you're digging into this literature
that there has been some inconsistency
in how that's used in the literature.
For the purposes of today,
I'm going to assume that
an experiment result
is reproducible when we are able
to obtain the same conclusion
using the same code
in analysis and using the same data
as the original experiment.
And so that's really in a
sense that minimum standard,
everything else on this board
is harder than reproducibility,
but yet that is where I'm starting
because I still think we
have a lot of work to do
to achieve this.
The notion of replicability
is when you actually apply the same code,
the same analysis, but on
data that is different,
so maybe you went ahead and
collected another data set,
and you see whether that's
actually replicable.
The notion of robustness
is when you might use the same data,
but you might have some
changes in terms of the code
or the analysis,
or someone has maybe gone from pseudo code
to a new implementation of the algorithm.
And finally, the lower right corner
is really what we're aiming
for in the long-term right?
Is to have generalizable results,
so if you re implement the
method, redo the analysis
using other data that
you get the same result
that's really this
notion of generalization
that we aim for,
that's the long-term goal
but for today I will talk
mostly about reproducibility
as being one step towards
that longer term goal.
Most of my work of course
is in the field of reinforcement learning.
From what I understand
you already had a day of amazing lectures
on reinforcement learning yesterday,
so I'm not going to get
back into the basics,
but just to ground us
this is really the setting
in which most of my work has been done.
And that setting aside really
impressive success in games,
that's where we've seen it shine
and it's made the headlines,
but it's useful to remember
that beyond those games
where reinforcement learning
has had some very visible success,
there's a long list of potential
real world applications
where reinforcement learning
could really be a game changer
in our ability to develop
some high-quality technology.
I mentioned a few of them
in the opening of the talk,
but there's actually a much longer list
that is under investigation
including some assisted robotic devices,
including some personalized
tutoring system,
forest fire management, and on and on.
And so, in a sense,
I'm not so concerned about reproducibility
for building systems that can play go,
or that can play poker.
I'm really concerned about
having strong reproducibility
for these types of applications
that are going to go into
everyday life of people.
In some cases may be playing a major role
in their health, in their
education, in their environment.
Let me take a pause
there before digging in,
and there's some questions about
some of the basic concepts,
and then I'll launch into the next piece.
Do we have any questions, Liam?
- Yeah, we have a few.
So Florian Gables asks,
"How is reproducibly affected by time?
I expect older papers tend
to be more famous papers
and thus are more likely
to be reproducible,
also in the last 20 years,
the ML field got away
from more competitive
causing more bad actors?"
Exactly right.
- Yeah, I think there's different factors,
we haven't done a timing analysis of it,
there's some things that
are easier from the past,
you know, computation
is rarely an obstacle,
we have so much more computation now
than we did 10 years ago.
In many cases, the types
of tasks that were done
that were attempted in those
earlier papers were simpler
and therefore by its nature
really easier to reproduce.
One thing that's harder is in many cases,
we don't have code from the early days,
whereas it's now become
much more common for people
to open source their code.
We also often don't have the same ability
to contact the authors,
and so some people have
moved out of research
and so on and so forth,
and so it's really not as
easy to get into the details,
so there's some of these
factors that come into play.
- Related question about publishing code,
I guess it's a personal asking
for your personal opinion.
"Do you think that publishing
code of implementations
should be compulsory for
publishing research?"
- I intend to be like not one
that dwells with absolute,
so I'm not going to go so
far as being compulsory,
I will say, I think it's
absolutely a responsibility
of anyone who engages in science
to be transparent in doing that.
So for me, publishing code is absolutely
a first step towards this,
I will say, even for
people working in industry,
if you're engaging in research
then publishing your
code should be expected.
On the side of data
I think it's a lot more nuance
how we think about that,
there are many reasons why
data needs to be treated
with appropriate confidentiality,
privacy standards,
whether it's healthcare data,
identifiable data and so on.
So there, I think we need a
much more nuanced discussion.
- Okay, great, and point
of clarification maybe
from the last slide on the
difference between replicability
and generalizability.
- Yeah, just going back
quickly to this one, right?
In replicability and again,
I'm really using a framework
that's proposed by NSF.
In replicability we
assume that the data set
is not necessarily the same,
but that the code and
the analysis is the same.
In generalizability,
you may actually have
slightly different methods for the code,
for the analysis may be
different storage system,
maybe different optimizer that's used
and so the results are in a
sense assumed to be, you know,
much more robust and
generalizable to other cases.
So the idea is really robust to variance
of both data and code in analysis.
- Okay, stop me when you feel
like we've done enough, but--
- Like last one and then
we'll get back to you.
- Okay, do you know if
there are any suggestions
on how to write
reproducible research code?
- We'll get to some of
that at the later phase,
and then I will probably
suggest some specific tools.
I think in many cases,
one of the things we can do to help us
is to have tooling and best
practices and guidelines
of how to do with that
so it's not general.
So in the last part of my talk,
I'll get into more specifics
in terms of tooling.
Both for code and more
generally for experiments.
- Okay, great.
- Let's tell a short part of the story
and we'll pause again for
questions maybe in 20 minutes
or so and also at the end.
So I mentioned that I have a
deep interest in applications
and this is where this is
motivated in many ways,
and so in some of the
earlier work that we've done,
we looked at developing
a neurostimulation device
for epilepsy.
So think of this as a small device
implanted in the chest cavity
that has electrodes
running into the brain,
some of these electrodes
are in real time reading the signal,
that EEG signal from the
brain from the patient.
And some of the other electrodes
are actually giving us electrical signal
in the form of periodic stimulation
to essentially disrupt the
neural signal in the brain
and the principle being that
if you disrupt the signal,
the brain doesn't move
into the state of hyper synchronization.
So epilepsy happens when all the neurons
suddenly decide to fire together,
but by adding external signal,
you're disrupting that
synchronization ability,
and that means that you can prevent
epileptic seizure in patients.
So these devices are in use in patients,
they stimulate different
areas of the brain
depending on the patients,
most of them are operating on
an open loop control system.
So they're just stimulating
at a particular frequency
without considering what
is the real time activities
so there's essentially
no sensing electrode.
And so in our work,
we really worked at using
reinforcement learning
to improve the stimulation strategy
in a way that we can reduce
the frequency of seizures,
the duration, and also reduce
the amount of stimulation
that's provided compared
to periodic strategy.
And so in this case, you know,
the signal we're reading
is a live EEG signal,
and in this case
we're really trying to
deliver the stimulation,
so here you see a case
of periodic stimulation
where every second the system
was essentially poked electrically.
There was already evidence
that this stimulation
at a periodic pattern was effective
in disturbing the patterns
of the hyper synchronization,
so preventing seizures,
but there hadn't been any work
on using adaptive learning
to improve the strategy
in terms of stimulation.
So that was the essence of our project.
And at some point later on
share much more of the details
of this experiments,
but it's sort of just set the
stage with a kind of safety
critical application
that I'm dealing with.
All of our work was done in
an animal model of epilepsy,
and so this is a slice
of the brain of a rat
that is put in a particular solution
where we can plant the electrodes
and observe the seizures,
in this case the seizures
are induced by a particular chemical
that's put in the solution
rather than a naturally epileptic animal.
And in that system,
we literally come in with a laptop
and plug in our stimulation electrode
and our sensing electrode as
input an output of that laptop,
and we run a closed loop
reinforcement learning system.
And so when you can imagine, you know,
whatever results we get in
this particular animal model,
we want to make sure that
they're actually transferable
to other live animal or humans cases.
And so this standard of
reproducibility is really motivated
by making sure that the
experiments I conduct
in the simpler setting
are really reliable enough
to know whether we should
move to the other settings.
And again, you know, if you want to go in,
read about some of the work we've done
that we've published a number
of papers on this topic
that the conclusion of it
was that after several months
of investigation this was
really a three year study,
we were able to show that
we could have as good of
a reduction of seizures
compared to some of
the periodic strategies
with many fewer actual
stimulation actions,
so that was quite positive.
But if you look at the
fine print at the bottom,
we spent about six months
building up the training data,
training the algorithm,
but then just the validation phase,
so running the experiments to confirm
that the RL trained
strategy was doing better
than the baseline took two years.
So imagine you're running an experiment,
you essentially get one experiment
that's going to take
two years and at the end
you will know whether your
algorithm works or not.
So thinking back to that pipeline
I had the experimental
pipeline on slide two or three,
you know, that phase of
going back and improving,
you only get to do it after
essentially three years
in this case.
And so the stakes are very, very high
that whatever you've done
in the initial phases
actually have high quality enough
and then you sort of run your experiment,
but cross your fingers
that it's going to work.
In our case, fortunately
we did have promising enough results
to continue to publish,
but that wasn't necessarily
going to be a second try,
and it's quite different
than a lot of the machine
learning experiments
that are being done today,
we don't do all of our work in this mode,
I have lots of other work where, you know,
you launch an experiment,
you go grab a coffee,
40 minutes later you have your results.
But I just wanted to bring to your mind
sort of the different cases,
depending on what the type
of application you're doing,
and you're trying to really solve,
it may be very different setting,
and there may be cases
where it's really important
that you up your game
in terms of the quality
of your experiments
otherwise you're essentially
losing three years
worth of work as well as the ability
to have a positive
health impact on people.
And so this is one of the
cases that's motivated me.
When you take on one of these
applications, of course,
as you can imagine,
you can't afford to just try out
all the algorithms out there
and really figure out
through trial and error
what works and what doesn't work.
We didn't have a simulator
for this particular case,
we had offline batch data to train from,
we weren't even able to train online.
And so there's a lot of constraints
that are imposed by the
setting in which you work.
And so we looked at the literature,
the set of papers that were available
to try to pick the methods that we thought
was the most promising one.
And as you can see,
there's a huge number of papers
published every year on RL.
And if each of these paper doesn't adopt
a really good methodology,
no matter how good I am
in setting up my own work,
if each of these papers on
which I'm basing my work,
doesn't use as good of a methodology,
I'm a little bit stuck
because I have to redo
all of their experiments before
even knowing how to set
up my own experiments.
And so in this case, you know,
I'm going to focus on a
particular study we did
trying to compare some of these algorithms
in the literature.
This is a little bit separate
from the epilepsy case,
we didn't do this insimulation,
but we were really trying
to dig into this question
a little bit similar to the article
from Edward Raff earlier
but in a much more restrictive setting
of policy search methods for RL,
what was the quality of
reproducibility of these methods?
And so we picked four
algorithms listed here,
and the reason we picked them frankly
is because they were
used often as baseline
across the literature,
so over and over again
we'd come with people
presenting new methods for RL,
but they were comparing their new methods
to one or a few of these existing papers,
so they'd become really a
reference set for the field.
And we wanted to know are
they a good reference set?
If your baselines aren't the right one,
whatever you compare to it,
it's going to be hard to
draw the right conclusions.
And we had a suspicion
that perhaps the way people
were using these algorithms
wasn't the right way
in terms of establishing
reproducible results.
So let me tell you a
little bit what happened
when we did this.
We consider the four algorithms
and this is not in any way
a critique necessarily
of these four algorithm,
it's really trying to
dig into this question
of how to run good experiments.
And so I'm not necessarily
going to tell you
which is better or not,
so don't base your own analysis on this.
But we consider this cheat on domain.
It's a classic of the Mujuco literature,
you essentially have a
simplified animated agent
learning to run,
so what you're seeing on this short video
is what happens when you were successful
in training your half cheetah
in learning how to run.
We applied the four algorithms,
as you can see, you know,
algorithm red turned out to be
better than the other three.
We then move to other cases,
there's a hopper and there's a swimmer,
and they're all using
the same kind of physics
and an observation.
And when we moved to these other ones,
we found that in hopper,
the blue algorithm,
which had been worse from
cheetah was actually the best.
When we moved to swim or
blue was doing really well,
again, but in that case
was really unstable,
and you see that by the
very, very large error bands
that are shown.
Whereas red was essentially
unable to learn.
So this is a little troubling
because those three environments
are actually operating
on very similar dynamics.
And so anything I want
to conclude from this
and take to doing a project
such as my epilepsy,
you know, stimulation system,
it's very hard to do when
even comparing a cost
across three, very, very
similar environments,
you get very different results.
So we started digging in a little bit
to understand what was behind
this really high variance
between the results.
We thought maybe we are
not getting the right code,
so, you know, one of the
reasons we picked these
is also because there was a lot
of open source implementation,
we had grabbed one that was
perhaps the best known one.
We went digging around and
found lots of other repos
trying to implement the same
algorithm and what we found
is if you take three different
implementation of TRPA,
which should be the same algorithm,
you get three results of this type.
And so if you'll go back to,
you know, my topology of robustness,
replicability, reproducibility, and so on,
you see what happens in
this case where same data,
different code based implementation,
and you see quickly that
the results are changing.
That's a little bit surprising,
but it's not unique to TRPO,
we ran the same thing with DDPG
and had similarly very different results.
We were not going to be stopped there,
you know, a big part of research
is just trying to understand,
and just like following
the piece of the story
that you don't understand,
and so, you know, in many ways
that's one of the good
qualities as a researcher.
So we started digging
into different reasons
that might explain the variation.
One of them that jumped out
is the network structure,
so depending how you were
setting up the neural network
that was representing your policy,
you had very different results.
We changed the number of layers,
the number of nodes per layer,
as you can see lots of different results.
We changed the activation function
that also caused the quite
a few different results.
We started digging into all
of these factors of variation
and found out many ways they vary jointly,
so we looked at the reward scale.
So in some cases, people
normalize the reward itself,
the reward function,
but then in other cases,
people apply normalization at each layer
of the neural network.
So there's definitely an interaction
between these two factors.
Really at the end of the day,
there was such a large number
of these experimental factors to consider
that that explained most of
the variation we were seeing
between these algorithms
and these methods.
So some of this is reassuring
because we understand
it's not black magic.
We understand what are the
pieces that are affecting this.
At the same time, there's a
large number of these pieces,
and we also observed a bias
in the way that the researchers
were sending their experiment,
in that the amount of work
that went into finding
the optimal configuration
of these parameter for one's own method,
wasn't really the same investment
that one was putting into
finding the best hyper parameter
for the baseline algorithm.
So I assume, you know,
many of you have read a
lot of research papers
in which you see, you know,
you're proposing a new method,
you comparing to a bunch
of baseline methods.
So really the tricky question is,
are you going to be as motivated
and spend as much time computation,
finding the right setting for the method
that you're proposing as you are
for the method that you are comparing to,
so previous methods in the literature
and, you know, human
behavior and psychology
being what it is, you know,
there's a strong suspicion
that people often don't do
this in a systematic way.
And while we might think that's
setting up a fair comparison
between method A method B is
easy, same amount of data,
same amount of computation we're done,
in practice, this is not what is happening
in a very large number of studies.
Let me show you one example
that was particularly revealing,
in this case, my students
ran two different methods,
the blue and the orange,
they came back and said,
okay, we were very tight
in controlling all the
factors of variation,
we ran five iterations of each,
we're averaging the results,
reporting the standard error.
And we get this difference, which suggest
that the orange method is
better than the blue method.
So, you know, this was after several weeks
of this work on reproducibility,
we said, okay, interesting.
So what are the two methods
you're comparing here?
And it turns out those two
were exactly the same methods,
same code in both cases,
same budgets, same data
for finding the hyper
parameter configuration.
The only thing that was different
is the set of seeds that were used
to run each of these experiments,
and the seeds come in because
there's some randomization
in some of the initial
conditions of the learner.
And so this is really
troubling because in a sense,
the same method, it seems
like there's an advantage
to one when in fact it's not supported.
So there was a little bit of luck
in how the seeds split into those cases,
but it's still very, very concerning
in terms of our ability
to draw a robust conclusion
from such an experiment.
And so it was good to step back and think
like how we actually measuring performance
of these policies.
In many cases, what we
show is that dark line
is the average over the test trial.
And then the colored bar around it
is really the confidence interval.
Many cases we look at a
95% confidence interval,,
the main factor that we get to pick
is how many experiments do we run?
And so in the example,
before we had run five
experiments of each,
I asked my student, why did
you pick five experiment,
is that the right numbers?
Should we pick more?
I said, well, we looked in the literature
and five seems to be like the
rough number of experiments
that people are running,
if nothing else seems
to be the mode the
experiments at the time,
this was a few years ago.
And so if you look at this, you know,
there's a funny thing that's happening,
this is the number of trials,
three to nine, mean some experiments,
some results were done
on three experiments,
other results were done
on nine experiments.
There's a funny thing that happened
that some of the papers
were only reporting
the top two or the top three results.
So they may be running 100 experiments,
but they were only going
to report the top two,
top three, top five results.
And that kind of strategy
was sort of creeping into the community,
and if you go today and look
at papers from this era,
and sometimes maybe even papers,
if today in reinforcement learning,
be very, very careful
about how they set up
this particular part of the experiment.
Let me show you what happens
when you only look at
the top three results.
So this is a case where I
ran 10 different experiments,
and let's say, I have a particular
baseline I want to beat.
So if I run 10 experiment
and I look at the results,
this doesn't seem very convincing.
I didn't draw the average
in confidence integral
but that doesn't seem very convincing
that, you know, we have
substantial evidence
that we can beat the baseline.
If I just keep my three best experiments,
this is what it looks like.
So suddenly I have a very
strong, positive bias,
and also the variance
appears much smaller.
So if the baseline
computed properly the mean
and the confidence interval
over several examples,
but someone comes along and they decide
to just show the top three results,
in doing so they will have a
fairly strong, positive bias
and a smaller variance,
and thus their method
will start to seem advantageous.
And so, unfortunately there's
many papers in the literature
that have done this over the years.
What's even more damaging
is when a set of paper starts to do this,
even people who are very motivated,
in terms of having good reproducibility,
which says you use the same analysis,
we'll use this particular analysis method
because it's the same one
as previous literature.
And we really get into a
culture of poor experimentation,
even though we should not be doing this.
And so the take home from
this, I think is twofold.
One of them is in reinforcement learning,
there are many, many sources
of experimental variation,
it's good to be of all of them,
and to be thorough in deciding
how you're going to control for them,
do it in a way that is
fair for your methods.
The second one is to be really thorough
in how you report your results,
and see 18 that were published
across the top conferences.
And we found that even though
all the papers had experiment,
used neural networks and
describe the hyper-parameters
for the new algorithms
that they were proposing,
in many ways on other things
that we would strongly
recommend that they do.
So, you know, one of them is making sure
that you thoroughly document
all the hyper-parameters
for the baseline methods, even
including a link to the code
so that people can actually
reproduce your methods,
specifying it, how you went about
choosing the hyper parameters
for all the methods
or algorithms in the paper,
running an evaluation on
a proper holdout test set,
and finally properly
running significance testing
to support the conclusion
of your analysis.
So these are all ingredients
that I think are very important
when reporting experiments
in reinforcement learning.
Also this applies to many other
fields of machine learning
to keep in mind, where
I think in many cases,
the community has fallen short,
as we see by this really brief analysis.
Let me pause here before
I jump into a few,
you know, solutions tools and so on,
let's take a couple of questions
and then I'll do the last bit of a talk
that is a little bit more practical.
This is really raising the alarm,
but I will provide you with
some practical suggestions
to avoid some of these pitfalls, Liam?
- Yeah, so there are
several questions there,
like what can we do? So I
will skip those for now.
- Pause on those.
- Don't cover them in the
next 10 minutes, okay.
So in my experience,
I've noticed a general lack of sensitivity
about the different test environments
and the different inherent difficulties
that some environments
have compared to others.
Very often articles
that propose experiments
in real environments
were compared to others
to analyze the effectiveness
of the algorithm
in small discreet and often
non-dynamic environments,
how do you think we can
increase the attention
of some researchers to
the large amount of work
prior to adapting an algorithm
from a toy problem to a real problem?
- It's really a challenge,
and we've seen this over and over again.
I will say that there's a
relatively small number of people
who are really willing
to get their hands dirty
and work with real world data,
I hope that many, many more people
would be willing to do that.
And I hope the upcoming
generation of researchers
will really engage in this.
You know, for me, there's
two really ingredients here,
one of them is transparency
to be thorough and transparent
in reporting the steps of your
research and the trade-offs
and the limitations of
anything you've done.
And secondly, it's really
entering always the work
from a mindset of
understanding of inquisition,
not trying to win any medals.
This is not the Olympics,
this is not how research is best done,
but really the spirit of inquiry
and of growing our knowledge together.
And those two ingredients, I think
if you keep that really top of mind
are the guiding lights for
doing this kind of work.
- Great, a question for Matthew McFarland
that I think you partially answered
in the last slides of your talk,
but given the large variability in results
for different implementations
of the same baseline,
does this mean we have to be skeptical
of all research we read,
how can we identify
the papers that present
raw results we can rely on?
- Yeah, you should always be skeptical,
at the same time, you know,
there's only so much energy you
can put on re-investigation.
I do think as the community of research,
we don't spend enough
time being skeptical,
reproducing work, investing and testing
the robustness of our knowledge,
versus always, you know, there's a real,
I'm not sure how to call it,
but like a fetishizing of
novelty that I think is damaging
to the quality of the research process.
And so I think we need
to invest more in that
and each of us needs to
carry a part of that,
and I'll give some tips on
that coming up in a minute.
Last question, maybe,
and then we'll conclude
and take some of the others at the end.
- Okay, great, so this is a
question from who, Cesarean,
in social science research,
reproducibility is not possible
because it varies very
dramatically over time.
How can generalization
be taken into account
in these settings?
- Yeah, and as much as you know,
I call for better behavior
in machine learning research,
I think in some of the other fields,
this is much, much harder to do.
And so we produce stability
as strictly defined here,
is as feasible as was
mentioned, you really,
but generalized visibility
always have the ability
to describe your approach
and results in another lab to carry that.
And so, in some cases, you
know, in clinical sciences,
it's really common to do
multi-center regular protocol
across several hospitals,
because we know that whichever
hospital ran the study
is a major factor in the
results when you do the analysis
of, you know, what are the causal factors
that explain the results,
the location is one.
So then we set up a multicenter study.
So I think there's some of this practice
of that can be carried to other fields
to help reduce that variance.
Let me jump in with a few recommendation
of where we're moving as
a field and as a community
and I'll take a few last
questions at the end.
You know, one thing I want to recognize
is machine learning systems are complex,
there's several aspects to consider
when building our experiments,
whether it's the code,
the implementation, the
machines were running on,
the system, the data,
also the social systems
in which we're embedding our work.
And so we have to be
careful of considering that.
Perhaps on that more optimistic side,
you know, we have dealt with
many, many other complex system
and I'm pointing out two of them here
because they've been an inspiration
to some of the solutions we've drawn.
One of them is, you
know, flying an airplane
was not always as safe as it is today,
put yourself back 100 years,
and really there was
a lot more uncertainty
about the outcome of any plane ride,
yet over time, the industry
has really raised its standards
in terms of ensuring safety
and it's remarkably more safe today
than it was 100 years ago.
And another case is really
what we're seeing in surgery
very much the same thing.
Surgery had been performed for centuries,
but really the amount of care
that goes into ensuring as safe procedures
has really improved in
the last few decades.
And they're both fields where
they've used very simple tools
to raise that, you know,
there's been of course,
amazing innovation at
the technology level,
but one of the simplest tool
that they have used repeatedly
is the use of checklists,
both in the cockpit
and in the surgery room,
a very prescriptive
checklist that the people,
the actors go through while
engaging in their activity.
And so in recent years,
we've proposed similarly,
a machine learning
reproducibility checklist,
it's available, it's a
set of different questions
that you can run through
for your own work,
that gives you high, your
certainty that you sort of checked
all the possible sources of variation
and with a goal to having
much more reproducible work.
So there's five sections in the checklist,
the first one is about all the models
and the algorithms you present.
The checklist is meant to be
used when you write a paper
for a scientific conference or journal,
but it can actually be
adopted much earlier on
in the process of conducting
a research project.
So for the models and the algorithms,
you want to clearly
describe what you're doing,
the assumptions, the
analysis of complexity
for the theoretical claim,
you want to make sure
you are stating it clearly
have a complete proof.
For the dataset, there's
several factors to consider,
and it's useful to be very
transparent about each of them,
be able to describe them.
For all the code that you want to share,
again, a relatively
short list of ingredients
that if you can include the dependencies,
training code, evaluation
code, pre-training models,
reading a file, it's
not really complicated,
but you would be shocked at
how many papers published
or they don't meet this basic standard.
And for all the reported
experimental results,
we also have a number of
items that we recommend,
including and checking again,
based on some of the analysis we did
of what were the missing pieces
in a purse in the current literature.
And for both, you know,
some of the sections,
in particular the code session,
we did a lot of analysis
on GitHub repositories
to see what was the correlation
between whether people had included
these really simple components or not,
and how useful was the
code that we're doing.
And we ran an interesting analysis,
looking at of the five items that I listed
the reproducibility checklist
if you had one, two, three,
four or five mil clump,
how that was correlated with
the number of GitHub stars
that the repo would get.
And we see that, you know,
packets that have all five ticks
are much more likely to have a
large number of GitHub stars.
So it seems relatively
simple in some ways,
and yet to be really disciplined
and diligent about this
is both going to have an impact
in terms of people's
appreciation of your work
and also the scientific
quality of your work.
So this is a set of really
practical things that you can do.
I will give you access to the slides,
so you'll be able to dig
into all of the links,
I do try to include on most of my slides,
the relevant links to get more information
about the particular topic.
Beyond this we also ran a
reproducibility challenge
for the last few years.
So we've invited people to take a paper
that was published at one
of these recent conferences.
The challenge runs twice a year,
all you have to do is
sort of pick up paper
and set up to reproduce
at least part of the
results of this paper,
and then write a report
about your reproducibility.
And once we have enough
submissions of reports,
we actually review them,
peer review the reproducibility reports,
we select the best one and
annually publish an issue
in the journal resigns with the
best reproducibility report,
so you can go and see
the issues of the journal
from the last two years are out already
and we're going to be preparing
a new iteration for 2020.
So this is another place
you can get involved,
even if you're not at
the stage of research
to produce your own innovative research,
you can certainly be a citizen scientist
and participate by picking up work
that has been done and reproducing this.
You know, in many ways and
lots of other sciences,
we spend a lot of time
learning the techniques
before carrying our own experiments,
and in machine learning, I
think this is a great way
to learn the techniques, to
develop your own expertise
in running some solid experiments.
And so if we look at what's
nuisance, maybe 2018,
when we started talking
about reproducibility
in machine learning,
at the time, I sort of gave a keynote talk
at nerds trying to call,
to bring to the attention of the community
that we should be doing
better in that respect.
Many things have happened,
we have code submission
policies at most conferences.
There's now a code tab that's
integrated in archives,
so when you look at a paper in archive,
you can also access the code,
and more recently the data set.
There's a lot of tooling that allows you
to sort of create a
tight repo of your work,
I'm suggesting a few of them
here, but there are more,
there's the reproducibility
checklist I mentioned,
the reproducibility challenge,
that issue of the journal resigns.
So all elements that have been put in,
in a sense we didn't invent
and you use science to do this,
we just made it common in the culture
and in the practice of our community
to have higher standards
of reproducibility,
which we're hoping will
help us as a community,
have more effect and more
impact with our research.
I'm going to conclude,
so I have time for a few more questions
before we have to close the session.
I think my main message is
really to keep top of mind
focused on the fact that science research
is a collective activity,
collective institution,
and together we aim to
understand and explain,
that's really the goal of what we're doing
and good practices in
terms of reproducibility,
usability, robustness are
important to contribute to this.
I will close here a quick acknowledgement
to the many, many collaborators.
who participate in the
work I described today,
who have been really inspiring me
to keep on doing this work.
Some of them were participants
in the summer school
a few years ago, and now
autonomous researchers,
so thank you to all of them,
and I will take some questions.
- Fantastic, talk to all really wonderful.
Okay, so first question
from Martin Varianke.
Can you share with us a project example,
which could act as a gold standard
to what we should consider a reproducible
or generalizable project?
I'd have to dig in to come
up with with one of them.
I think one place to start
is actually in the journal rescience
where we've done the
reproducibility issues,
and I'll be sure to add
that like on the side
where you can actually access that easily.
There's a number of
reproducibility reports there,
and you'll get a really nuanced discussion
of which were, you know, good or bad,
these are all based on
recently published papers.
So it will give you some concrete examples
that have been vetted, peer reviewed,
both the original paper and
the reproducibility report.
- Okay, great.
Could you please provide some
examples, papers, et cetera,
of current applications of RL,
in terms of simulating the environment
after multiple agents take actions,
so it's a little bit of a different angle.
- Simulating the environment
after multiple agents take actions.
Yeah, I'd have to think a
little bit about that one,
maybe someone wants to follow
up with me an email on that,
or I think we're going to
do some Q&A in writing,
so maybe move that to the writing section
and I'll try to dig up some examples.
I will say I've seen
some interesting cases
in autonomous driving,
where there's multi agents
that are all carrying actions
that depend on each other.
I've also seen some
interesting cases in games,
we had a paper a few years ago
on playing the game of
diplomacy with multiple agents,
so those are a couple, I think,
fun applications of this.
- Cool, question from Adrienne Kindle,
a cause of the reproducibility crisis
is the selection bias in publishing
where insignificant results
were rarely published,
which incentivizes researchers
to pick their best results.
I think the selection bias
in publishing also exist
in reproducibility venues
and could impact which papers are tested.
What have you found successful
in motivating researchers
to reproduce research,
given the risk that results
may not be reproducible?
- Yeah, that is definitely
a strong factor.
I think on reproducibility results
were a little bit more neutral
because we don't have as
much of a strong party
of whether it's going to
be reproducible or not,
we're really engaging
fundamentally with the question.
So I think it's a little
bit less of an issue.
There's definitely a
bias, we see, for example,
in the reproducibility challenge,
we let people pick what
paper they want to reproduce,
there's definitely a selection bias there
of what papers people
are picking versus not.
And we can nearly cover
the set of them all,
I think, you know, a
conference like in Europe
says upwards of 1000 papers
and through the reproducibility challenge,
we tackle maybe a couple
of hundred of them.
So we're not close to coverage.
One of the things we've done
is really encouraged this challenge
to be taken on as a project
in machine learning graduate courses,
I think it makes a great final
project for anyone out there.
If all, you know, graduate
level machine learning courses
would take this on as
their final course project,
would really make a dent in terms of that,
and really reduce that selection bias,
which is problematic right now.
- Great, how do you think
we can encourage researchers
or organizations to
enforce better standards
in a systematic way,
ie not hope the authors
are well-intentioned,
can we enforce it more in hindsight?
- Yeah, for the last three years now,
Neuro Rx has adopted the
aversion of the checklist.
and it's evolved a little
bit through the years,
but the checklist is used
at these major conferences
like Neuro, CML as part
of the submission process,
so the authors actually
have to fill it out
and then it's actually
visible to the reviewers,
and so there's an
accountability mechanism there
that gets built in this year.
It was particularly clever,
they built it into the
lead tech style file
that the authors have to use,
so it's really, you know,
changing that behavior
through the structure and
the tooling that's provided,
I think that's one of
the most effective things
we can do to change this.
- I like this question,
so very often reviewers suspect
of cherry picking up RL environments
because only if you're presented,
while for small research
centers with limited resources,
those are the only ones
that could be tested,
while big brands have plenty of machines
and can show lots of environments,
how can the community be improved
with common criteria for everyone,
and I think balancing the, like, you know,
the availability of compute
with the requirements reproducibility?
- Yeah, it's always a challenge,
like if you're picking the environment,
you're essentially like setting the bar,
and then you're showing that you can,
you know, jump over the bar.
That's always a bit of
a conflict of interest,
so, and then at the same
time, we have to acknowledge
that the resources are
not always the same.
I want to point out a paper
that was written by Pablo Castro
and some of his colleagues
at Google last year,
I think it was really showing
that there's still a lot of
value that can be obtained
from looking at smaller domains
and reinforcement learning.
It's a beautiful paper that
I think is worth considering,
especially for people
who come particularly
from institutions where you
have small access to data,
perhaps not data, but compute.
The way I always think about it
when I discuss with my students
and it happens to us all,
so it's always like, yes,
it's fine to show results
on a small set of domains,
but are you the one who
are picking the domain
or can we actually lean
on picking the domains
that someone else has picked?
So we pick these five domains
because these were the five domains
that were used using this other paper?
So we're not picking them
ourselves, we're adopting them
because someone else suggested them.
So I think there you
reduce the cherry picking.
The other thing is to some
degree, selecting environments
is perfectly acceptable
if you explain what's
your selection criteria.
And so I think we're at a phase
of maturity of our research,
that it's very rare that
you will publish an app
or find, discover an algorithm
that will be better on every domain,
everywhere all the time, right?
So if you can focus on a
smaller class of domains,
but you explain why for
that class of domain,
this type of algorithm is better,
then I think that's
perfectly reasonable to do,
but you know, the cherry picking is not.
- Great, I also like this question,
so it's hardest not to fool ourselves.
Well, what questions can we ask,
what tests can we run
to prevent human nature,
especially for someone newer to research?
It's very hard, right?
- Richard Fineman has a
beautiful quote of that,
which I sometimes use in
some of my talks about,
you know, you don't want to
fool anyone, but you know,
the easiest person to fool is yourself,
something to that effect.
Yeah, to me, that goes
back to the mindset.
It goes back to a mindset of
inquiry and an understanding,
and it goes back to a strong
commitment to transparency,
and really finding
that that is what drives
us as researchers,
otherwise we're sort
of in the wrong field.
One thing I didn't say is
all the work that we did
on reproducibility that I shared today,
you know, the comparison of the results,
the not doing the top three picks
and so on all of that
came about in our lab,
because not because we
set out to do this at all,
we were trying to produce
the standard paper
where we had a new method
that was better than
all these other methods,
and yet it wasn't,
and as we started digging
into why it wasn't,
this is where we discovered
all these really odd things
that other people were doing,
and so at that point, we sort of pivoted
and decided like this was
the more interesting story,
it was no longer a story
about showing our algorithm
it was more interesting,
it was much more the story
about what were some of the practices.
So sometimes, you know,
keeping an open mind
about what is the interesting
part of the research story
that you are apt to tell
at a particular time point
in our field is it's something
that you should follow.
It's harder publishing a
paper with negative results,
it's awesome, but it's harder.
So, you know, really
solicit all the advice
and the support you can get
from experts and colleagues,
lean into that collective
wisdom to do that kind of work.
It's really rewarding when you do it well.
- Yeah, that's the great
example of following your,
I guess, scientific and
intellectual curiosity,
and I'll look at how much
impact this work has had,
which probably, I don't
know how great the method
that you're thinking of publishing was,
but certainly the impact
of this work has been huge.
I think we should probably close it there.
We're two minutes over,
thank you so much, Joelle
for the excellent talk,
very thought provoking
and wonderful as always.
And so with that, I'll close
this procession of the day
and we'll look forward to
seeing everybody later on
in the further lectures
and then the career fair
and everything else.
Thanks again.
- Thank you, thanks Liam,
thanks everyone, bye bye.
(soft upbeat music)